we first saw his talent on So You Think
You Can Dance and his daytime moves on
Ellen DeGeneres but tonight
the shocking news that Stephen twitch
boss took his own life this is
Entertainment Tonight hearing this news
was a gut punch to all of us who knew
him twitch was a devoted husband a
loving father and a beautiful soul who
always shared his light with E.T
[Music]
we're still making sure that that
kindness and love is still spread
I love that it's a Boss family outing
tonight yes it is absolutely
we love the Full House and also just to
like family man like honestly they're my
favorite they're my favorite people you
know what I mean E.T confirmed the sad
news the 40 year old dancer and DJ
committed suicide at this Encino Motel
less than a mile from his home Ruth
Cardenas who was staying there says a
housekeeper knocked on twitch's door
yesterday morning around 11 15 they went
and checked I'm gonna knock on the door
she didn't really see him but she knows
the body and that's it and then she came
out she's freaked out he was pronounced
dead at 11 25 a.m reportedly from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound this
morning Ellen posted this pic with him
backstage and called him pure love and
light
twitch's joyous public Persona makes his
suicide all the more shocking just three
days ago he posted this video dancing
with wife Allison the day before they
celebrated their ninth wedding
anniversary and last month premiered
their last project together
the hip-hop Nutcracker on Disney Plus
a source tells E.T Allison is beside
herself it feels like she is living a
nightmare in a statement she said he was
the backbone of our family the best
husband and father just last year I
visited them at their new home in Encino
you guys are relatively in a new house
which is gorgeous we actually just
painted painted maddox's room their son
Maddox is six daughter ziya is three and
their oldest daughter Wesley is 14. Al
Allison and twitch told us they were
considering having more kids we'll see
we'll see it can go either it depends on
the day you know twitch started DJing on
Ellen in 2014. in 2020 after DeGeneres
faced allegations of a toxic workplace
he was named an executive producer
there's a lot going on in the world
right now and a lot of things that need
to be addressed she's up in a high place
and people love to take cracks when they
got time filming the last episode of
Ellen that it was really the the end of
an era I'm still in a lot of shock this
morning we spoke to twitch's friend Jody
Sweetin at the wraps power women Summit
have you reached out to Allison at all I
have I just texted her I just wanted her
to know she's left he's such a talent
and such an amazing warm wonderful heart
and yeah he will be he will be greatly
missed
[Music]